le 24 février Vladimir Poutine ordonnait
l'invasion de l'Ukraine ce que le
président russe appelle une opération
spéciale aurait pour but de des nazifier
son voisin un discours qui rappelle la
grande guerre patriotique menée par
l'Union soviétique face à l'Allemagne
nazie en 1941 et si Vladimir Poutine
était en réalité l'héritier d'une
vocation impériale des tsar russe quel
lien entre l'invasion de l'Ukraine Yves
encaque Le Terrible Pierre Legrand ou
encore Catherine II au fond comment les
arts ont fait de la Russie un empire
pour comprendre il faut remonter loin
très loin l'histoire de la Russie
commence par une légende
issue d'une chronique slave le récit des
temps passé rédigé par un moine au 11e
siècle en 862 riorik un prince vareg nom
donné aux Vikings venus de l'actuel
Suède aurait uni les tribus slables et
fonder 9 gorodes pour créer le premier
état slave de l'histoire 20 ans plus
tard Oleg un parent de ryourick
s'installa le long du fleuve nièpre avec
ses troupes et prix qui a fil proclama
la mère des villes russes toujours
d'après la chronique si il est difficile
de prouver l'existence de ryotique ce
que l'on sait avec certitude c'est que
des guerriers et marchands Vikings se
sont bien installés le long du niepre et
ils fondèrent la ruse de Kiev un
ensemble de Principauté Kiev devient
alors un centre économique et culturel
important auquel le prince wolodimir
donne une identité chrétienne byzantine
en se faisant baptiser en 9 un épisode
au coeur d'une histoire commune entre
russe et ukrainien et qui fait dire à
Vladimir Poutine que l'Ukraine est russe
Poutine voit le baptême de volodymir
comme l'événement qui fonde la parenté
spirituelle entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
la Russie comme l'Ukraine reconnaisse la
rose de Kiev comme leur berceau
d'origine et le prince volodymir comme
un héros qui est révérée des deux côtés
de la frontière mais en 1240 la ruse de
Kiev fut dissoute par l'Empire mongole
en 1480
Ivan III qui règne sur la Principauté de
Moscou proclame son indépendance
vis-à-vis du jour mongol entre temps il
unifie progressivement les peuples
russes voisins par la force et la ruse
fondant ainsi les bases de la nation
russe un état qui est en constante
expansion en opposition au monde
catholique à l'ouest incarné par le
royaume de Pologne Lituanie et face à la
montée de l'Empire ottoman musulman au
sud le pays doit se défendre face aux
raid des Tatars venus de Kazan la
stracan et de Crimée contre lesquelles
Ivan IV dit le terrible considéré comme
le véritable fondateur de l'Etat russe
constitue une armée et construit des
fortifications passant à une stratégie
offensive la conquête des canettes
musulmans de 15 ans en 1552 et d'Astra
Kahn en 1556 à un but purement sécurité
car elle met fin en partie au raid la
Russie devient alors un empire
plurinational et pluri-confessionnel
elle s'ouvre alors sur un immense espace
géographique mais aussi économique sur
la steporasienne via la mer Caspienne et
vers la Sibérie que des entreprises du
marchand de fourrure Stroganov ainsi que
des paysans colonisent progressivement
une expansion qui se poursuit au fil des
siècles mais alors comment justifier cet
empire qui va devenir immense en
arrivant au pouvoir Yvan Le Terrible
invoque une parenté avec l'empereur
romain Auguste et veut faire de Moscou
la garante de l'orthodoxie la troisième
Rome c'est à dire qu'après la Rome des
Césars et l'Empire byzantin lézard
serait investis d'une mission
civilisatrice
orthodoxe une vocation universelle qui
serait le moteur de toutes les conquêtes
russes au fil des siècles selon
l'historien britannique Arnold townb il
est vrai à l'appui de la pièce de Tony
que cette idée d'une troisième Rome
apparaît dès qu'110 dans une lettre d'un
moine
orthodoxe qui s'appelle filoté mais
quand on regarde toute l'histoire de la
Russie a traversé nombreux péripéties
rien ne permet d'affirmer que
rapidement ce rêve d'une troisième Rome
qui a mis la logique impériale au fil
des siècles quand on y regarde de plus
près il semble bien que finalement la
logique de l'empirus ça a été celle de
tous les empires depuis Alexandre le
Grand c'est-à-dire que tout empire qui
cesse de conquérir devient peu à peu une
proie pour ses voisins et il se condamne
par la petit à petit à une mort certaine
au début du 17e siècle une période de
crise appelée le temps des troubles qui
voit l'arrivée d'un fozar au pouvoir et
l'occupation de Moscou par les troupes
polonaises la Russie est à deux doigts
de sombrer c'est une nouvelle dynastie
qui la relève les [ __ ] il l'étendent
à l'Est très fortement mais aussi à
l'ouest en annexant l'Ukraine oriental
par le traité de périaslave en 1654 un
traité à la fois symbole d'histoire
commune et de controverse entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine encore aujourd'hui
mais le Romanov vont surtout tenter de
faire entrer la Russie dans la modernité
une transition fortement incarnée par
Pierre Legrand qui rêve d'Occident
réaliser son pays et fait des réformes
dans ce sens ces réformes renforcent
l'armée et la marine russe pour
permettre aux jeunes arts obsédés par
l'accès aux mers d'acquérir des
territoires contre la Suède au bord de
la mer Baltique où ils fonde sa capitale
Saint-Pétersbourg bâtit sur le modèle
des villes européennes en particulier
françaises et italienne mais les
réformes civiles ne sont pas assez
profondes et suscitent même l'hostilité
de la société elle ne permet donc pas à
la Russie de sortir de son état de
puissance pauvre selon le mot de
l'historien Georges Sokolo une politique
que Catherine II montait sur le trône en
1762 continue tout en voulant renforcer
la puissance russe en Europe elle a
grandi l'Empire en lui donnant accès aux
maires dites chaudes la mer Noire et la
mère d'Azov après la prise de la Crimée
au turc ottoman un accès qui obsèdera
souvent les dirigeants russes pour des
raisons stratégiques et économiques avec
son projet grec Catherine II se veut la
protectrice des lieux saints et des
chrétiens dominés par les musulmans
Ottomans dans les anciens territoires
byzantin notamment à Constantinople mais
elle veut aussi établir en Europe un
empire chrétien
son projet grec c'est d'abord un projet
géopolitique mais il a une dimension
messianique notamment à cause de ce côté
panne orthodoxe et c'est intéressant
dans la mesure où vladim Vladimir
Poutine lui-même en 2014 en parlant de
la Crimée qui est justement la porte du
Sud Poutine a comparé la Crimée à
l'équivalent du Mont du Temple à
Jérusalem ça dit bien que cette
dimension messianique est encore à
l'oeuvre dans la Russie actuelle une
volonté de puissance qui s'illustre lors
du partage de la Pologne avec la Prusse
et l'Autriche entre 1772 et 1795 la
Pologne une nation importante au passé
ancien disparaît donc pendant près de
130 ans une inquiétude qui résonne
encore aujourd'hui dans ce pays en
première ligne dans l'aide militaire à
l'Ukraine au 19e siècle l'Empire s'étend
à la Géorgie et au Caucase à la Finlande
en Asie centrale et jusqu'au confins de
la Chine pour des intérêts économiques
et commerciaux les derniers arts
agrandissent l'Empire dans une rivalité
de puissance avec la France et le
Royaume-Uni qui sous-tend les conquêtes
coloniales du 19e siècle une rivalité
illustrée par la guerre de Crimée en
1853 en 1904 le dernier tsar Nicolas II
en proie à des difficultés politiques
intérieures déclarent la guerre au Japon
notamment pour le contrôle de la Corée
cela se termine par une défaite
humiliante qui marque un coup d'arrêt
elle entraîne des troubles une
révolution en 1905 et réveille les
nationalismes affaiblissant l'Empire à
la veille de la Première Guerre mondiale
la défaite face au Japon lors d'une
guerre que Nicolas II ne voulait pas
entraîne un processus menant à
l'abdication en 1917 de celui qui reste
le dernier tsar de Russie elle illustre
un débat qui anime l'histoire russe au
fond l'Empire forgé par les tsar a-t-il
été un poids pour la Russie selon
l'écrivain Alexandre
soljenitsa aurait été un fardeau pour la
Russie en raison du trop grand nombre de
peuples à assimilé l'empêchant de se
moderniser une logique impériale que
reprendra l'Union soviétique mais en
habillant
communiste alors même que Lénine
qualifiait cet empire de prison des
peuples Poutine il est l'héritier de
toute cette histoire impériale qui s'est
déroulée au fil des siècles et donc il
est animé par l'idée que un empire qui
cesse de conquérir un empire qui cesse
d'avoir des protections assez frontières
et condamnées à mourir à brève échéance
or justement la protection des
frontières a considéré à boirement
reculé depuis la chute du mur de Berlin
et depuis ensuite la dissolution de
l'Empire soviétique or Vladimir Poutine
voit depuis des années l'avancée de
l'OTAN après la guerre froide jusqu'au
frontières de la Russie comme une menace
pour son pays c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons invoquées pour justifier la
guerre en Ukraine avec l'invasion de son
voisin le président russe renourait donc
avec la stratégie des 15ème et 16ème
siècle voyant la conquête comme un moyen
de défense mais qui peut aussi se
retourner contre lui la Finlande et la
Suède ayant décidé d'adhérer à l'OTAN
après l'agression russe en Ukraine cette
vidéo est la première longue série si
elle vous a intéressé n'hésitez pas à la
partager mais surtout n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner au Figaro Histoire si vous
voulez en apprendre plus